we could have gone to 11 12 13 seasons
but they I guess they wanted a life you
wanted it to keep going well it you know
if you've read that my novels you know
there was enough material for four more
Susan so they made certain cuts what but
that's fine we have five other shows
five prequels and development that are
based on other periods in the history of
Westeros some of them just a hundred
years before Game of Thrones some of
them 5,000 years before Game of Thrones
and I'm working on other projects Nettie
and I are working on a book together
this is Nydia Cora for she wrote an
amazing book called who fears death that
HBO has options so I'm an executive
producer or net and we're developing
that to be I hope then one of the next
big is real fantasy series how did you
know Game of Thrones would be ending
with this season or did they call you
and tell you hey let's have a chat
David and Dan have been saying for yeah
like five years that seven seasons was
all they would go and we got them to go
to eight but not any more than that so
yeah I had a custom a custom that there
was a period like five years ago where
they were saying seven seasons and I was
saying ten seasons and you know they won
they're the ones actually working on it
so our character that you would love to
see a spin-off with no I'm committed to
these prequels I mean I think this story
ends when it ends and I know all the
actors as great as they are all the
actors are anxious to get on and play
other roles they don't want to spend
their entire lives playing one role and
that's fine I mean there it's great
there we had such an amazing cast I mean
not only two people here tonight but
some people couldn't make it like Maisie
Williams sophie Turner
sibel Kate Kelly you know Marc daddy who
played Robert and the first thing great
great great cast I was honored to work
with them
oh you know to be honest the the final
seasons taking along tour taking a long
time because it's the biggest thing
we've ever done and even though it's six
episodes
it took us
how many more shooting does the normal
burning would you say I mean it was it
yeah so it was nearly a full year in
Belfast I they're prepping it or
actually shooting it and it's I think
it's quite extraordinary what the crew
and these actors have created and I
think when people see it they're gonna
understand they're gonna understand why
it took so long so it's really not it's
no one's going on vacation no one's
slacking off it's just that last season
is far beyond what we've ever attempted
before and it's taken a really [ __ ]
long time but uh I hope it'll be worth
it
everybody is Charlie and I to which Game
of Thrones would have gone 13 seasons I
think we can all say that if you didn't
catch it Martin also dropped some
interesting details about what's
happening with those other prequels that
HBO was developing because remember the
long night is the one that they're
filming starting in February next year
so let's break it down there's a new
round of that 4k season 1 blu-ray
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
the video when Martin talks about them
doing the book material and cutting a
bunch of stuff out if they were to do a
direct adaptation and do everything that
was in the books it would have to be way
more than 13 seasons like we're talking
about dwarfing the Walking Dead in terms
of amount of content when he says Dan
and Dave originally only wanted to do
seven seasons there was actually an
interview after season 7 came out Dan
and Dave clarified they'd always wanted
to do a 70 hour movie what ended up
happening is is that in the later
seasons the scale of the action and the
special effects just crushed their
budget in their filming schedule so hard
that they needed to spend more time
actually filming the episodes and
because they were spending so much more
money per episode they had to decrease
the episode count so that was one of the
reasons why we only got 7 episodes in
season 7 and while we're only getting 6
episodes in season 8 so when you add
those up you end up getting 73 episodes
so you get a little bit more than they
originally wanted to do but it sounds
like what would have happened is had
they gone more than you know what
they're currently scheduled for is that
they would have left the show new show
runners would have come on and usually
when original creative leaves a show
that they've been with for that long
it's usually not good for the future of
the show so imagine all the complaints
that people have had about the last
couple of seasons
defied a thousandfold he also kind of
talks about the other work that he is
doing so Martin also would not have been
able to help them Shepherd those later
seasons either because he has winds of
winter and dream of spring to finish and
he has those other TV shows that he's
working on in all the Game of Thrones
prequels that he says he's still
committed to so that's actually probably
the more interesting thing in all this
because a little while ago when they
confirmed that the long night prequel
was the one that they were moving
forward with they start filming the
pilot for that in February I believe
they go back to Belfast for that because
even though King's Landing did not exist
during the long night period most of the
other big locations like Old Town and
Winterfell they were just fine like most
of Westeros was still there there were
just a couple modern houses that hadn't
been created yet but Martin actually
says that he's still committed to five
prequels now they did say that one of
the prequels was dead but it sounds like
based on the way he talks about them
they've just put them on a shelf and
they're just doing one at a time what
they decided that the long night is all
they need for now and they'll revisit
those other ideas in the future if you
haven't been keeping up with corporate
culture right now AT&T is in the process
of buying Time Warner there's this big
merger that's going on in the AT&T
people want way more premium content
from HBO there was a comment made by one
of the top executives that they're gonna
have to step up their game in terms of
their output so a lot of people just
expected that they would produce more
Game of Thrones because that's sort of
their marquee show they have a couple
really good things like they have
Watchmen that's coming up but it just
seemed like it was going to be a Walking
Dead situation like recently The Walking
Dead people said that we're gonna be
making a whole bunch more spin-offs we
have a Walking Dead movie that we're
planning on making so it just seemed
like they were gonna do the same thing
with Game of Thrones as a property at
HBO which is worrisome because usually
when you ramped up the output that much
the quality dips quite a bit so I think
HBO is it's like no no no we're just
gonna do one prequel at a time we're not
gonna over saturate the market and
dilute the brand that much so I actually
think that that's a good decision on
their part so that doesn't mean that
they won't have say like two prequels
running in four or five years we'll just
have to wait and see the only two other
prequels that Martin has confirmed that
they were not working on and they
weren't going to do was Robert's
rebellion entails
Duncan egg the Avengers have sir Duncan
the tall an egg on the fifth who was one
of maester aemon's younger brothers who
became king of Westeros for a time he
actually mentioned him right before he
died the reason why Martin said that
they're not doing Robert's rebellion is
because they're already covering most of
those events through the characters
conversations in present-day on the main
show and through the flashbacks like
Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna Stark
so it's just so close to what's
happening in the timeline right now
that it doesn't feel quite different
enough in any prequel spin-off series
that they have would have to balance a
certain amount of familiarity like it's
to us to feel like Game of Thrones but
it can't be the exact same plot which I
know is really interesting because the
long night involves the rise of the
White Walkers and the night King so I'm
curious to see how they handle that part
of the story depending on which part of
the timeline in the long night that they
pick up the long night itself is a
pretty easy slam-dunk period for them to
tell because you have a good number of
the same major houses that exist
it's said almost 10,000 years in the
past in history from that period has
only been loosely spoken of and Old
Manse tales legends in apocryphal tales
that have been passed down through oral
histories because everything that was
happening then happened before the
maesters were created it really wasn't
until they came along that history
started to be recorded in a very
accurate way they kind of had a joke
about that during season seven so
there's just a lot of room for Martin to
create new lore during that period for
them to turn into story so that's why
he's helping them with that one he was
involved in various degrees with the
prequels some more than others the long
night was one that he had a bigger hand
in so he helps give them their roadmap
their character histories the geography
established the continuity I think
probably the most important part of just
the characters and the continuity so it
doesn't trample on anything that's
happening in present-day
some of you have also noticed - the
really interesting thing about that
period in history ancient history is it
that in most legends the rise of the
Valyrian freehold Valyrian standing
dragons for the first time happens
around the same time as the tail end of
the long night so there is a bit of
vague overlap but remember history is
very unreliable so there are no exact
dates for everything so let me know in
the comments what do you want them to do
in the east during this long night TV
series that's come
remember it's not supposed to premiere
till 2020 probably sometime in the
spring really hoping that they drop the
first teaser for that after they air the
finale for season 8 but I think it just
depends on how much footage they have to
show off leave all your requests for
bonus videos in the comments below
congratulations armaan Jain you're the
giveaway winner from my last big video
please email me on the about page of my
channel so I can get your details click
here to learn all about the early
release date for season a great news and
click here for my season 8 trailer video
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome we'll see you guys tonight